thank you dr. Lainey for agreeing to be
interviewed for our living history
project I'm sure that you feel good to
know that you're a piece of living
history I'm living it's it's a pleasure
to be sitting here with you and talking
just to set the context a little bit for
your career
at Emory you were an undergraduate at
Yale University where you majored in
economics and then served in the
military in Korea and during that time
in Korea you experienced a kind of
change of direction and felt called to
return to Yale for training in the
ministry at the Yale Divinity School it
was a result of that that you went on to
serve as pastor in the Methodist Church
and eventually as a missionary and
educator in Korea and then you returned
to Yale again where you completed
completed a PhD degree in Christian
ethics in the record time of two years
from start to finish
Jordan was what twenty-one months even
better
I think the Guinness Book of Records has
that but then you were off to Vanderbilt
as a faculty member in a fairly
prestigious Divinity School where you
might have chosen to live closer to home
and pursued a career as scholar teacher
and minister and so I'm wondering why
after three years or what what it was
about Emory and the Candler School of
Theology that attracted you to accept
the deanship at Candler in 1969 after
only three years as an assistant
professor at
well of course at Vanderbilt I had a
good view of theological education as it
was practiced in a very good school and
I both learned a lot there not only for
my teaching but also in watching the
administration and how they dealt with
curriculum and they really the formation
of students for the pastor it and I
began to get ideas of my own that were
not always the same as those that were
being entertained at Vanderbilt as a
result when the inquiry came in my
middle of my third year there from Emory
as to whether or not I might be
interested in being considered for the
deanship I was fascinated but not by
anything so long because I knew so
little about Emory at that time that
being a Methodist even I knew that it
was a Methodist University and I knew
that it had a theology school but I
really wasn't for me with it firsthand
and for that matter I had never been to
Atlanta so so one of the things that
fascinated me when I arrived in Atlanta
at the airport even then I don't you
know this is this is a real city and I
was comparing it with Memphis and
Birmingham and the other southern see
that this is outpacing those and it
certainly had a lot more vitality and
energy than than Nashville and then I
came out to the campus and was impressed
and Emory as it is now is still being
discovered and I realized you know this
is this is this is for real and I
thought you know this could provide an
opportunity to try out a lot of the
ideas that I developed in Advanta be and
really were part of my own sense of
emerging call and vocation particularly
regarding education and when when
things really became serious I also
discovered that there was great
potential here I mean real opportunity
having the combination of a vibrant
southern city that sort of was leading
in race relations which were very
important to me and a University which
had huge potential particularly in the
Divinity School the theology so when the
offer came I accepted it gladly because
it was first of all it was taking me
back into the church Vanderbilt that was
not connected formally anymore to this
church and I thought you know also it
might have an opportunity to shape
theological education and the way or
influence it that would affect for good
the church would have a positive
beneficial influence on the church
itself on the pastor it and Silver's the
formation of pastors and the the
successive influence on the church that
that and the opportunity that all
provided that brought me here and I've
never looked back
when you got to Candler then in 1969 you
must have had clearly some some goals
and intentions what what specifically
did you have in mind in terms of shaping
theological education through Candler
and and how did you set about trying to
change those goals or move the faculty
toward them well first of all I was very
deeply committed to contextual education
in a sense a modern counterpart would be
service learning the the sense in which
you are put into a situation it was
vicariously at Harvard and other law
schools and business school with case
study but in this instance you really
enter the situation itself with all of
the emotional and and other overtones
but under supervision not only of the
person who is an expert in it in one
case a clinical pastoral education a
hospital or this institution similar to
that or an urban setting I was in I was
very much interested in getting the
pastoral students into more than just
the hospitals I wanted them to
understand the urban problems race
problem probable poverty and healthcare
and that sort of thing and so we set up
a series of practicums you might say in
which all the students who were in the
pastoral program the ministerial program
had to take one full semester or its
equivalent in one the CPE where they
learned to be in supervision and then
the next year in an urban setting and
then finally we did it in terms of the
church itself identifying churches that
we thought modeled good ministry and
care for the parishioners and the role
in the community but the unique thing
about it that was doing it that
intensively was probably somewhat of a
pioneering effort at that time although
now I think it's pretty commonplace the
thing that was really unique was
insisting that the faculty themselves
participate in this move out of the
classroom this this has some very
interesting reverberations and I was
enormous ly helped in this by Charles
gherkin whom I recruited from Grady
Hospital I was very impressed with him
and brought him out as a member of the
faculty teaching but also who would
oversee the the whole program and meet
once a month with a faculty who were
participating what what this meant was
if there were 12 supervisors who were
professionals there were 12 faculty
paired with those each of those who each
had 15 students or whatever and the
faculty were expected to reflect
theologically in behalf of the students
was it turned out in behalf of
themselves and gherkin was a master at
helping shape the faculty and overcome
their resistance which we would all have
I mean this is not a criticism it's just
natural
so that out of that we'd not only got
more closely aligned with the students
and their struggles but also the faculty
themselves would begin in a forge a
community because they were sharing all
of was sharing something in common now
that that was a rotating thing they
didn't have to do that all the time but
they had to do it on a regular basis and
it continued to have some resistance
because of the pressures of you know the
academic pressure but I think that was
the most important thing that we did
because it had an impact on the student
body it also created community with the
faculty and a bond with the students and
I participated myself so I know what it
was like and it meant a great deal to me
there were several other aspects to the
opportunities that Canada provided one
was at that time the ministerial
education fund of the Methodist Church
which had actually begun out of the old
one and two percent plan that Henry
Bowden and Buster Byrd and DW Brooks had
started back in the 50s with Dean
Trimble had now gone nationwide was
beginning to move into high gear and
that was providing significant funding
for the Methodist seminaries and Candler
was getting about almost a million
dollars a year which was a lot of money
at that time so I persuaded President
Atwood to let Canada be a table on its
own bottom I just thought we could do it
and this was a relief to him because
Candler had been subsidized by a
substantial amount every year by the
general university funds so we were able
not only to that gave a lot of freedom
in terms of how much new faculty we
could add as long as we could pay for it
and we could carry over our balances at
the end of the year which had not been
done before was they never had about us
so we could build up a reserve in other
words so within the first three or four
years we added twelve net faculty to two
of faculty that at the room and that was
almost a 50% increase these are all
bright young faculty was a huge change
and theological education is a small
universe and that caused a lot of waves
around the country that Canada was doing
all this you know and so that was me and
then the third thing was came a little
later was the opportunity to purchase
the Hartford seminary library which
catapulted us from nowhere to number two
in the country and among theological
libraries and really was a marvelous
addition not just in terms of numbers
but in terms of quality and range and
so all of that began was a sort of a
yeasty mix that kept everything bubbly
but in a great spirit and the course I
would have to say that having brought
Jim persuaded Jim waits to come with me
from Nashville out of the pasture it and
he was at that time very relative very
young and we just saw eye-to-eye we we
had a team that was ran so easily you
know just one friction and sort of thing
we had all these young faculty who had
all their energy and you could use that
this is this is a new infusion not only
intellectual capability but of just
plain physical energy and so the
excitement was palpable and it was a
great story you know we really were
doing I remember about the fourth year I
was there someone said there's a new
ranking out among the theological
schools and and canlib was ranked way
you know Cantor never been ranked
anywhere and he was ranked way up I
don't know tied with Princeton or
something and you know up in the top
pantheon of the top half-dozen or
something and all of a sudden you know
it was new it was a bracing realization
there's a real cultural change in
suggesting about all of it and of course
concurrent with that all of a sudden
Candler was being regarded in a new way
and within the university because you
know this is a school it was really
moving and I have to say it was because
we had these new funds and that enabled
us to get the new people and then we
were able to obtain the library and all
that and there was just a wonderful mix
and just great great spirit you know I I
look back upon those eight years as
being as productive and as happy as any
I've ever had
one of the things that excites me about
the theology school now as compared to
what I imagined it was in those days
particularly in the late 60s is that
theological education has many more
women than it did now they're probably
well 1969 was only seven years after the
university had won the right to admit
african-american students without tax
penalties women were still fairly new at
Emory let alone at the theology school
what was the transition like what was
going on in the theology school in terms
of the integration of the classrooms by
both african-americans and women oh well
we we began of course since there was
gammon across town we we it was not like
there was no theological education for
Methodists african-american ministers
but we began recruiting very very
aggressively and gradually built up the
numbers and I think about 1971 I
recruited Grant Shockley to Candler he
was the first full professor
african-american full professor in the
university I think that's correct and he
brought a wonderful spirit that the
pastoral spirit to the whole school
and so that eased the whole thing the
other thing that we did was in this
contextual education when we began
having seminars and churches as part of
our supervised ministry we paired them
with a number of African American
churches and I myself taught a course at
Cal Houston's Presbyterian Church down
near the what's now Turner Field across
the interstate and cow they had 12 lay
people and we had 12 students from that
church in Cal and I co-taught that that
course for
full semester and those kinds of
experiences were marvelous in moving us
along and helping many of the southern
white students to become at ease with
the old issue of integration I don't
mean to say it was seamless or
effortlessness or thing but it never in
least a Candler didn't pose them but the
bear issue came because of the quick
movement of the number of women's
students and we had to make a
corresponding shift in our whole a self
understanding ethos because you know you
vocabulary changes and so many things
changed with that as well and then we
also had the issue of my last several
years of the more conscious
participation of the gay community and
and their demand appropriate demand for
recognition and participation in the
community that probably set up more
hostile reaction than any of the other
two and I remember we had some real
confrontations in an assembly where you
know I just sat and dealt with the
questions and all that many of the
students who were very uneasy with this
had raised but you know I look back on
that and there's this there was a kind
of residual I don't know what I call it
goodwill but there was a fund of
community that kept us from fracturing
too badly there was milk plenty of
strains but we didn't you know fall into
dis factions and that's were
aggressively hostile groups at each
other's throats
the theology school really had risen in
stature nationally in its ranking let's
say and the graduate division of
religion began its line upward in many
ways the the pockets of religious study
throughout the university were
academically at the fore and yet 1976
Sanford Atwood announces that the
following year he's going to retire as
president and you come to the floor as
the candidate for the presidency I
imagine that there were some skeptics
around the university no skeptics about
the prospect of having this research
university led by a Methodist minister
or the Dean of the theology school what
what was let me ask you first of all
what what it was that led you to
consider moving from the deanship of the
theology school to leadership of the
university and then how did how did you
address the skeptics out there well I
don't know how address the skeptics
except by action but part of it was the
growing confidence that what we were
doing was wasn't appropriate so we're
setting the pace for the university I
mean obviously disciplines vary and
schools have the curriculum all that but
the ideas of what made for outstanding
educational experience I think were
valid in themselves
I had broadly khaki from Vanderbilt in
72 I think to head up the Graduate
division he went on seven years later to
become Dean at Yale and then in 1974
christa stunned all who was Dean at
Harvard invited me to come up as a
visiting professor I had a leave coming
which had already been approved by the
president and so forth so we went up
there and it turned out very quickly
that what they were doing was look
over for the possibility of his
successor and I taught a seminar there
and you know realized and I was
interviewed by trustees and of course
got to know Derek marcano I realized you
know that what we were doing at Emory
was was of that was of that measure I
mean I didn't we didn't have anything to
apologize for I mean Emory was very good
and there was a kind of a new confidence
built on the fact that I had already
served while I was Dean on the visiting
committee to oversee the Yale religious
life and Divinity School I served on the
committee on one chair of it and was
confident that you know what we were
doing was was you know it was good it
didn't that no apology to anybody and it
didn't take second place to either
Harbor to Yale well with that kind of
confidence and the fact that because
Henry bound and some of the other
trustees knew that Harvard was looking
at me they already when I came back in
75 began saying well you know we'd like
for you to consider the possibility
being president now there's a lot to go
through and all and very the integrity
of the process but they they want they
wanted me not to leave in other words
and I was comfortable with that because
I felt that if it should work out that
way and I knew a number the trustees
that you know we would have a a team
that we'd have the trust as unleased a
handful of the trustees backing it and I
had the confidence then that what we
were doing could be drawn on a larger
canvas I don't mean everything but the
general idea is the direction University
and so I think out of that and the kind
of entrepreneurship that was
involved with the Hartford seminary
purchase which bother we got a whole
page in the old times in the second
section or something back then which
they said was the largest transfer of
books in American history which we loved
all that you know and so out of that
grew that the thought that if it if the
mid should come to me I certainly would
not be averse to taking it you know I
really you know once something that I
had consciously sought that I can say
that but as it kind of evolved then like
as the likelihood of it increased or the
prospects my confidence that it would
not be inappropriate all seem to
correspondingly increase I think that's
the only way to say it you know I didn't
I didn't feel it all intimidated by the
thought of working in the whole
university as opposed to just a theology
school
you mentioned the Hertford book
collection purchase which certainly was
a bold move and I think the beginning of
your presidency really is a series of
bold steps it may not have felt like
that at the time but just shortly after
you became president you and the board
agreed to launch a major fundraising
drive I think when you became president
you announced that some of your
ambitions included raising the level of
scholarship funding down professorship
and or so on and clearly you also had a
vision for enhancing campus life and
student life
but it was really in 1979 the
announcement of the hundred and five
million dollar Woodruff fund transfer to
Emory that came as a blockbuster piece
of news and was was really a bold bold
step before the university garnered
national attention as the largest gift
to higher education in American history
up to that point say a little bit about
what led to that gift and how that was
nurtured and and what some of the
thinking was behind that both in terms
of the university administration and the
trustees of the fund well I think to
answer that I'd want to say first of all
that within three months of my zooming
office as president I did lay before the
trustees a whole list of things that I
wanted to try to accomplish and I looked
back on it I you know I haven't want to
be careful this is not said in a
patronizing way but I really saw myself
as an educator in every sense of that
word my role was to articulate and
educate the trustees that is you know to
help them understand what what we were
about and if they will if the goals were
worthy to get their support educate the
faculty as to what we were trying to
accomplish together in addition to their
own
working no and course to educate the
students and how did we do that most
successfully and so constant it was
always on my mind to try to articulate
to try to set forth constantly what
we're about in why and why it's
important and how we might get there and
of course and to get there and it means
enlisting support so in that sense it
was an act of persuasion nothing but
rhetoric I learned this way back in the
rhetoric of of touching the common cords
of response the people shared and then
building on that you know so in a way
you develop confidence and trusting you
move forward I think that trustees were
a little they sort of caught their
breath when I laid out when I thought we
needed to do and begin to look put a
price tag on because it was really very
aggressive for Emory at that time and
you know they're always there's a
question of well do you really need this
I mean know these ambitions or you know
these real are these just personal sort
of things you know and you know you you
have to they have to buy into the vision
that this is not only what should be
done but it can be done and that if in
doing it we really will accomplish
something that's worthwhile you know
we're not just gonna keep along with the
status quo and so so I set that forth
now the interesting thing is that mr.
Woodruff won on the board so I had to go
over to see him a lot to keep him up and
up to date with what was going on back
here and in those meetings I wanted to
share with him what we were about and we
had some interesting talks and
particularly the time when he said he
didn't didn't believe it endowment we
were trying to raise a lot of money for
endowment when it turns out that was
based on his thought that the endowment
was idle capital and it took me about
two three weeks to figure out idle
capital will the opposite of idle
capitalism
working aha that is a term that they use
in business is working capital so we we
simply transliterated endowment into
working capital he bought it something
that was fine but once he signed on that
wasn't a question of what he was doing
but he had to begin to get a sense of
the enthusiasm and himself participate
in this in the positive spirit that was
and so that that was a took a while of
course it was two years and something
after I became president before without
the gift the gift itself of course grew
out of the issue of what mr. Woodruff
would do that all along the question was
this will be a successful campaign and
mr. Woodruff gets behind it and
initially as you may know the Emily and
Ernest Woodruff fund which had been an
endowment set up by Robert and George
would esperen
had been a foundation and had been
turned into a fund to avoid certain
problems for the RS namely the payout of
5% as a fund it only it only needed to
pay out the income which is uh wasn't
different and the funds income was set
in order to meet our requirements said
it and the institutions that would
receive it and Emery was set to receive
no less than 40% he could receive more
but no less of the income and then a
whole bunch of other institutions
received the other 60% and and the
trustees of it were the ones that made
the decision as to how the distribution
would be and I remember of one of the
things that Jimmy Sibley not talked
about very early on and Jimmy Williams
was maybe we can get the trustees of the
fund to raise the payout to Emily from
forty to sixty percent which would be a
big in you know a lot if the pun was
worth over 100 million Oh that'd be
equivalent of twenty million dollar the
income from 20 million dollars
but in the process the thought of that
and thought that George Woodruff that he
and Robert were going to die you know in
a not too distant future led them
particularly George to say why don't we
just turn the whole thing over to Emory
I mean the corpus well the difference
between receiving a portion of the
income and getting the whole corpus is
enormous because of course the growth of
the corpus over the next 15 years was
just unbelievable I mean the hunt those
3 million shares of Koch they were
transfer to us the market value today
would be way over two billion dollars I
mean if you wanna say wow what would a
gift comparable to that make a splash
today well two billion dollars would do
it but that was big money and anyway
George took appropriate pride in George
Woodruff in sort of helping it
mr. Woodruff of course had to be
enthusiastic about it he although it
wouldn't have happened without his
say-so cuz he was the dominant brother
but I remember and I want this for the
record in addition to Jimmy Sibley and
Jimmy Williams
in addition to those that I've named who
were played a just an absolutely key
role in seeing that this happened was a
garland Herndon who at that time was
some vice president for Health Affairs
at Emory Merlin was mr. Woodruff's
personal physician and had become very
close to him as a confidant and garland
and I often worked and talked with mr.
Woodruff and the kind of intimacy that
that allowed in terms of helping
establish the confidence was it was
really very important the second thing
was up until the time of that gift all
the monies that had come from us would
have been gone into medicine or
medically related fields they finally
got it enough to build the chemistry
building one time on the basis that it
was pre meant but would her from the
Robert Woodruff library was built with
government money and other funds it was
not built on a Woodruff funds in any
case the gift came without restriction
that is on its use and how although they
said it we'd like for it to be endowment
they didn't even I don't think there was
any restriction on that it was um and it
was for the University and that was a
godsend because then without you know we
could begin to make plans for the whole
university not not slighting medicine
but putting it in perspective you know
in the total picture the other thing
that happened about that time was the
the growing conviction that we ought to
try to sequester the Woodruff fund from
the general endowment then general
endowment when we received it was I
think about a hundred and seventy-five
million dollars so that fund alone was a
forty percent increase of our endowment
and took us above Duke in Manorville of
course there
whole campaign raised I think 200
something and so we we really increase
the endowment considerably more as well
as raising money for projects and that
sort of thing but the idea of
sequestering the thing was that we
wanted to see if we couldn't continue
the the power of initiative within the
university once it gets built in to the
budget an income stream it its power is
there but it has no no an additional
impetus into the budget or into the
programs and we succeeded in in
persuading the trustees honor they've
won hard to persuade them because they
always like to be conservative but it
was a hard grow for the faculty and some
of the faculty were extraordinarily
critical of the first few years of our
use of the fund because they didn't see
the immediate results in fact some rode
in the wheel that they thought that
somehow was had some sort of chicanery
what is incredible
but in any case in the first working out
of this since we had set up scholarships
and wooded professorships and special
project like that as being the first
call on it was a need for a huge
infusion in the Emory college and
scholarships we just it's hard to
believe what the scholarship budget was
when I took over I think it was less
than a million dollars but the whole
college we were just so heavily tuition
dependent you know and that constrains
us d Norma's Lee and David mentor who
was then the deans him and he said we
need 20 million dollars 20 million
dollars I don't remember what we finally
wound up with but it was a substantial
amount but we agreed that we would start
off the first year with that amount and
the next year we would well it would
grow and then we'd back out
they grow year by year we you know and
come in with the freshmen and so forth
but then after four years we'd begin to
back it out and we did and the college
put it had built gradually built it into
their budget well the point of all this
was to try to leave at least 50% of they
would have fun free and unencumbered so
that we could do matching things and
pull back and so forth and I think that
worked for a long time I know that I
think probably by now it's long since
been been fed into the budget but that
enabled for at least 15 years to start
initiatives they were just invaluable I
mean we could just simply do things you
know I mean not just bill buildings
we're more importantly programmatically
and often it when abled us to match
things get get funds from foundations
and other foundations around the country
the to carry out these initiatives
you have early on after receiving the
Woodruff gift appointed a what amounts
to a blue-ribbon committee of chaired by
our alumnus Distinguished Alumnus Howard
Lamar who was then I think Dean at Yale
Dean of Yale College later later for one
year president that's yeah yeah that's
right
I'm just wondering to what extent the
process of that committees work and and
the recommendations of that committee
help to guide well it was invaluable in
many ways both for the substance of
their recommendations things like
scholarships professorships are generic
which professorships which programs to
back up in other words some
professorships require you know support
particularly for research and which
library works you know all of that is
tied in that committee was invaluable in
establishing those priorities and making
recommendations and did the faculty
buy-in to the that committees worked
well they did that partly because that
committee said you have a unique
opportunity here with this this infusion
now if you use it wisely you can really
move emory ahead and i think most
faculty believe me partly because of the
the sheer distinction of that group ii
all of them came from very distinguished
universities and in their fields were
stellar and consequently they carried an
authority that was very much needed both
for our internally here and with our
trustees and they met a number of times
across the campus with respective groups
and faculty and all they did a marvelous
job their report was very seriously
weighed and implemented to the point
where when Howard Lamar came down and
met with our trustees I think it's C
Allen or someplace in the late 80s he he
was very
laudatory and how well we had actually
been how faithful we had been to the
recommendations in getting them done
I want to come back to something you
said earlier about power of persuasion
and the art of rhetoric and the
importance of rhetoric and language to
the presidency and the university or to
any leadership position one of the
phrases that people appropriately
associate with your presidency is phrase
the education of the heart this was the
title of an address you gave at Harvard
and it was later the title of a
collection of your speech as an essays
and I'm curious about how you arrived at
that phrase how you came to that not
just that phrase but to that concept as
a kind of guiding emphasis of your
leadership well really this was a
formulation that kind of grew out of
this idea of education as formation I my
own education at Yale particularly in
the Divinity School and my two-year
stint as chaplain and as English teacher
at joke school a boarding school in
Connecticut convinced me of the age the
age old business going back to Plato one
of the importance of formation education
is not merely theoretical it's it's a
total person and that values are
inherent in what's going on and what's
important how we choose this and that
and what attracts us and what repels us
all of that is part of it is simply a
matter of exploitative and trying to the
desiccation of higher education because
of the excessive specialization and the
pressures on the faculty to be
accountable to their disciplines
nationally and their professional
organizations rather than either to the
their own institution or their students
that that tension that they live with
this is not a criticism the fact that is
life as we see it today nevertheless
tended unless there was a countervailing
force then it would pull the faculty way
in and there they felt that their
assessment in their work was primarily
by their peers and that's very important
part of the quality but also an
important thing is the the dynamics of
the classroom and the interaction of
faculty and students and I over and over
again I'm impressed when some of the
finest faculty and the most
distinguished scholars speak of how some
of their best insights come from
seminars with undergraduates because
there's a free-flowing kind of
interaction and that scholarship and so
forth
not just the pursuit of a laser-like
thing but but that freshness and
impromptu quality and it was that aspect
in formation and how people really you
know while we might back away from in
local parentis the fact is that faculty
have a huge influence on us to what
students think and how they feel their
their view of life I mean they really
want a size that they want to find a
student they don't want to be told and
they don't certainly don't want it
imposed and make it a requirement but
they are constantly taking their cue
from faculty and from mentors that's the
whole point of what a mental means it's
not just what you've learned from them
consciously but all that and then and
you know and the issue of in law and in
medicine and other thing of
apprenticeship and an internship no it's
only carries with it that kind of weight
and in the so it has to do with judgment
as well as knowledge that comes out of
this kind of education and I don't know
where the phrase came from Gary but it I
think in it was an evolution a series of
speeches that I developed talking to
teachers actually and then Harvard asked
me to speak to the National Association
of
nine heads and so I gave that speech and
the the editor of the Harvard magazine
was there he said that is so radical
radical
well yeah Plato's radical and and
Rousseau is radical you know all the
great philosophers of education you know
I think back of my own education and
this this is where I got it is it's this
hardly novel but in many ways it guided
I would imagine you're thinking about
campus life programs it was certainly
the contextual education that he spoke
about in all of that and my desire to
get a better campus life experience for
students was was part and partisan
Testament indulging the students it was
really an attempt to make more conscious
and a given more positive spin to how
they experienced and the extra crucial
act that all the things that go on on
campus that are part of the education
you know and it was that and anyway the
Harvard magazine published this speech
was supposed to shock and all that on
the Harvard audience the Harvard faculty
are they read it in yawn
let me turn to something that that
really was a kind of coup one among many
in your presidency after President
Carter's defeat for re-election in 1980
he was offered I think a number of
possibilities to affiliate with various
universities but he ended up joining the
faculty at Emory and beginning a
collaboration with the university that
has been rich and varied over the last
two and a half decades how how did you
recruit a former President of the United
States to the Emory faculty what went
into that
just went open asking becoming know it
really began with Hamilton Jordan coming
approaching me
our son Tom was working as a theological
student intern in Washington at the
White House he got that on his own not
through me because I didn't really know
President Carter that well and I'm and
and Tom our son Tom knew Hamilton and
Hamilton wanted to see me and he said
I'm leaving the administration
regardless of the election and I'd like
to come and spend a semester or a year
at Emory as a visiting scholar or
something like that and I want to write
a book so we worked that out but in the
process we had some talks about what if
what if President Carter didn't win and
so when that Santa virtuality occurred I
was prepared to talk with President
Carter and had an access to him through
Hamilton Jordan we got along well we
share a lot of the same thing we have
Southern roots
we're both religious you know we both
tend to be more alive more moralistic
and you know the things that he talked
about wanting to do other things that I
thought would be good for him he to be
allied with and certainly do for him to
be on the faculty and all so one thing
led to another and we partly our
friendship developed into a part
but I really didn't although we had been
to the White House several times we were
with a large group and it did not
indicate anything while he was president
I was I was not close to him when we
developed the friendship later and I
think the quality of the Carter centers
work and its success as a testimony to
the validity of his establishing the
center and of our association with him
there was certainly a great great
achievement it has been a great addition
to the university but there have been
many wonderful achievements in your
presidency what do you think of as as
the high point of your presidency or the
greatest piece of your legacy as
president of Emory University I don't
know to the extent that we were able to
sort of institutionalize some of the
ideas and the education of the heart I
think that part and parcel with the
greatest frustration that is I don't
call it a failure but just a frustration
that the gap between the reality of of a
community of scholars and all the
richness of connotation that implies and
the fractionated light modern life of
specialization where people have very
little in common and the careerist
orientation of the students trying to
overcome that so that they would be in a
way receptive if you have a goal that is
so clearly defined I have this problem
in theology school I know what I want to
be I want to be this kind of a preacher
well that's exactly what I wanted to get
out of it I mean you'd help them and
it's not that you wanted to destroy it
if you wanted to set it aside and let
them really develop and not have a
foreclosed kind of maturation and I
think that was the gap go back to the
earlier point between my ideal of a
community where really there was a lot
shared in common and we had
cross-disciplinary conversation and the
students were involved in thing and the
reality of modern wort life and I think
that tension exists you know wherever I
think the importance is to maintain that
tension and the same thing is on the
campuses where the tension is lost and
it just simply has given over to
specialization and and the society's
definition of what life should be I've
always felt and I guess this comes out
of my background as a minister but the
prophetic aspect of the Old Testament
that a university in a college should
always be standing in critical stance
toward culture not in not in rejection
not necessarily in opposition but always
in an appraising stance and so I have a
lot of problems with much of modern life
which wants simply an endorsement of the
career ISM and the success motif and the
unlimited grab for money and that sort
of thing the extent of which Finance has
become the end-all of the university
life it's funny than somebody who tried
to get the Woodruff kid would talk like
that but you know I'm really I'm it's
very sad to see a kind of an
unquestioned evaluation of things in
terms of just in terms of money I've
never known it to be so meretricious and
that's why I think this idea of
formation and community of scholars and
all that holds some ideals that are
intentional that is so important and I
really believe that the university
should embody in some sense the soul of
a nation and not just be its cheerleader
now I'm beginning to beginning to
indulge in the rhetoric even talking
about but I can't help it I really feel
so passionately about this and the point
is is the funny thing is when you begin
to really talk about it not in
accusatory or judgmental terms but in
terms of aspirational term a lot of
people agree now whether that's going to
change their life they're not matter not
but I think that this is it's very
important for students to they graduate
with a thought that they might find
fulfillment in something that is service
and not just in terms of Act
one legacy that you helped to create as
the School of Public Health where a lot
of that sense of service to the world
Jews resides very strongly in its
parents in the in the whole ethic center
and the Center for religion and and law
all of these are attempt you know they
loose of enormous attempt to bring
things together not just so people could
talk and sort of have a coffee klatch
business with the faculty but so they
could really be from defined by other
fresh ideas and find out that there is a
great big world out there and then it
actually can have something to say to
you you know this is the year we are in
a university I'm not here but in any
university with all this wonderful
collection of stuff and so little of it
is understood or appreciated by those
that are outside the discipline and you
just like to see a little of that
movement going you know the quadrangle
climate Chicago is a wonderful place
where people from all the University
meeting and share meals and drinks and
and just talk across all kinds of
disciplines and you know I think that
this continues to hold a real pull
toward me for me and I'm confident that
Emory will be pursuing these things
because they're universal these are
these are not these are not sectarian or
idiosyncratic I hope
I thought I would ask you for some
impressions or memories of some of the
Emory leaders and benefactors and great
lights that you encountered during your
time as president henry Bowden senior
geralyn of the Board of Trustees when
you know Henry was suah generous he was
uniquely Emery beloved by Emery and
unqualified love for every he and his
generation of Emery graduates back in
the 30s ran the university for a long
time he and Paulette ermine and both
Leigh Jones and of course Jake Ward and
a whole bunch of others were involved in
that Henry was really the one who
recruited me for president I wouldn't be
president I wouldn't have been president
if he hadn't been for Henry he had he
believed in me at thinkin despite the
fact that I was Minister and feel you
know and I want to say here that I can
understand why faculty would have been
very uneasy because you know they'd gone
through the god is dead controversy and
the church didn't come out too well on
them from the standpoint of academic
freedom although Emery stood tall and
that was at woods finest hour
and Henry Bowden backed him up that
established Emery is not a little church
school but a serious university with
with church relations but in any case
Henry just knew everybody and everything
and of course he was a great rock or a
contour and that made it minute meant
that you know he could always give a
speech at the drop of a hat and he was
like the Pied Piper and I learned so
much from him
you know how to deal with people in a
gracious way and not simply a hectoring
way this is a tendency ministers you
know and he was a dear Methodist and I
think as long as Henry was around indeed
I be Brooks and others they saw to it
that the church understood Henry and
they kept the church at bay from the
standpoint of being intrusive because
they were able to assure the church that
Emery was doing its job I think when
when they pass from the scene it left a
vacuum that was hard to fulfill and I
was here when they know I remember the
difficulty were going to have including
Glenn the difficulty of getting after
all the here we got it in a sense the
chapel on the school we that we had no
control over who was preaching in it and
that was a long-standing point but
anyway Henry was such a remarkable
person you know there there are a lot of
people like in there who really have
loved every in the long wind in a way I
realized that I was an outsider who came
in and I had to learn to love the see
Emery from their standpoint and not just
in the Emery that I thought it ought to
become and the combination of those two
is a powerful thing
let me ask you about a faculty member
that's legendary now passed from the
scene George Patton Oh
George I call him my beloved curmudgeon
George and I got acquainted when Vernon
on our children were in Oxford when I
was Dean at the theology school in
Oxford England he was over there on
leave and we were there for a term and
we just got acquainted we had to saw
each other a lot and became real good
friends I think up until that time the
last thing he would have ever wanted was
the thought of a Methodist minister
being president of Emory but I think
after that we became friends and it was
not if it was not something he endorsed
it was something that at least he could
live with but I of course he was they
what do you call it the not the beetle
but the chief Marshall chief Marshall
right and he took great pride in that
and he helped me design my president's
robe and we had a great time we we would
often disagree and it was a wonderful
disagreement because we we could really
snarl at each other and never mean it
one of the first Woodruff professors he
recruited was Richard Elmen big Ullman
was a lovely human being and the
marvelous scholar at that time was the
Goldsmith's professor of English
Literature at Oxford and we were able to
get him to spend half of a year here
every year as would a professor Elmen
and his wife Mary were marvelous
addition and they I think they raised
the visibility memory across the
Atlantic by choosing to come here and he
was such a gracious soul that instead of
being seen as an outsider and a sort of
a you know snob or something coming in
from fancy places he quickly became a
real colleague of not just of English
but of art in Arts and Sciences and I
think did more to allay the anxieties or
uneasiness or standoffish nassif acally
about these new appointments because he
was so fine so sieve he he and I became
really good friends and we visited him
in Oxford and all I might add as a as a
footnote they used to live at Clifton
towers when they stated when they were
at Emory which is not far from low water
and at that time our paper was delivered
on Clifton Road at the mailbox which is
a half a mile from the house and I'd
look out in the morning and here would
be Nick almond and what I called his
fast trudge this was jogging but it was
hardly John and he would drop the paper
an hour at our doorstep and keep going
around the circle now though whoever had
a more sublime paper with paper boy
pollard Terman
determine because eventual senators
named Pollard Pollard was one of those
along with Henry Belton he was willing
to do anything for Emery and when we
were without a Development Officer very
early in my presidency he became the
acting to a vice president for
development which means as it meant his
office at that time was down the hall
and he became a very dear and trusted
adviser me invaluable he because he was
both a trustee and and he had you know
he really wanted to see things work out
and we had some some fairly rocky times
I might say that Henry Bowden came to me
one day and he said Jim three members of
Arts and Sciences all of them full
professors have told me that you're the
worst appointment was ever made of it it
was sooner we could get rid of you the
better he said what do you think about
that house it I don't think much of
myself he said I told him I said just
give him another year or so and you're
gonna change your mind and Pollard was
one of the people who could interpret
what we were trying to do to the
trustees in a gracious way you know it
was really important to have people on
your side who who could who could speak
in your behalf about issues that might
be either misunderstood or seemed too
ambitious or little ants you know people
made people uneasy and Pollard was just
a marvelous person in that regard and of
course he was very generous both of the
tall Foundation and also there's no
money with memory Pollard ranks were up
there with with the top memory graduates
just a superb human being I spoke at his
funeral and I remember I thought Pollard
is everyone's best friend everybody who
knows him thinks that Pollard is his
best friend that's him
he was Berner always said he's he is the
best gentleman I'm there
extraordinarily fortunate and being able
to become friends with mr. Woodruff we
spent a lot of time together and the
more time I spent with him the higher my
opinion of him as a human being was he
he had the most ineffable smile I've
ever seen on a man he didn't always
smile but when he did it was absolutely
winsome and I could see why as a younger
man he was so successful in whatever he
did because he just had this marvelous
innocence charisma in that sense not
rhetorically but personality was and I
remember once when his birthday was in
December the sixth thing and the first
year I was president I was racking my
brain to think what can I give mr.
Woodruff for a birthday present and
Alistair Cooke had come to the campus in
October to deliver the Robert Jones
lecture the Bobby Jones lecture and when
he the next week when he gave his weekly
voice from America he spent the whole
time talking about Emory hmm and he
raved about Emory and he said it was the
most beautiful campus he had been on an
Americanism far better than Berkeley or
Princeton or apotema and so I through
some friends I got hold of that tape and
took it down to issue a where mr.
Woodruff always celebrated his birthday
down at his plantation I was it was
absolutely unheard of it to say that you
wanted to come home mr. Woodruff's
birthday and invite yourself but I did
and they said you can come in through a
clock ya know stay for dinner okay so I
took a tape recorder and played it for
him the alistair cooke thing where he
was so high
and I left and from then on I got an
invitation on my own to come for the
birthday every year down there to etch
away and we had a good time you know
hunting was included in that but it was
we shared a lot and you know I looked
upon him in a way as a kind of a father
figure he was a lovely human being and
he was always interested in what we were
doing in every he wanted me to tell him
all we were doing I don't mean the
minutia but the big things and he was so
proud of it and after this is an
employee good story after we and the
Woodruff gift had been announced it was
on the front page of New York to him
home he he said doctor he never called
me Jim dr. Lainie do you do you know how
much money buck Duke gave to Trinity
College and I said I've heard it was 40
million dollars mr. winters he said and
how did they show their appreciation I
said you know they changed the name of
Trinity College to Duke University he
took a second month and I said I think
that was appropriate don't you mister
wouldn't you know I do and you know what
your gift is the largest it even beat
that gift
he smiled they said yeah and that was
the end of the conversation
I was I was so afraid he was gonna ask
me directly but he never did he he had
the best na taste
the reason coke became so universally
known and and you
I don't want to say love but accept it
is because the association where there
were always of impeccable taste he had
it was just natural to him and he also
had impeccable manners and so he would
go up to the edge but he would never
cross over and he never seemed to bother
him at all that we didn't change the
name of the University
let me maybe close by asking you a
question that's more psychological than
anything perhaps I without getting into
the specifics of all that has happened
at Emory in the 12 years nearly 12 years
you left to become the ambassador to
South Korea you must
it seems to me think from time to time
about your legacy and what you were able
to do with your colleagues at Emory and
how how does one just to take it out of
the personal realm how does one reflect
on that legacy a decade after the fact
and and how does one hope for the future
and and what comes after how do you how
do you reflect on what you were able to
do and and what you hope still can be
done as a result of that well first of
all I don't have any concerns
institutionally about Emory Emory is
flourishing beyond far beyond anything I
could have imagined when I was here I my
confidence in what we were trying to do
in terms of the spirit of Emory and the
educational philosophy is so fundamental
that is my confidence that it it's so
necessary and right in timely and I'm
pleased at Emory is carrying that on and
I believe that this is very important
for higher education not just for every
so when I think about legacy or whatever
you want to call it institutionally I
don't really it's not something I think
about much because I have such pride in
where Emory is and no worries about it
will in fact become it continue to be a
great institution and my real commitment
and concern and this is sort of grows
out of
it's really the issue of the nature of
education and I long for that to be that
tension I spoke about earlier to be
maintained here and and to be fruitful
that it be a fruitful tension mutually
fruitful and I'm convinced that it will
be because there are enough trustees and
the administration cares about these
things you care about these things and
that that's you know something I don't
really worry about it I have a concern
in that only in the sense of which I
wish it were more broadly acknowledged
and pursued so in a way my I don't want
to call it a legacy my interest is in
how that the spirit of education really
informs this nation I mean I guess my
time in Korea in government has given me
a sense of the nation I don't want to
sound grandiose at all but I really
those are my greatest concerns what who
are we as a people what are we doing and
how does education fit into that and
just to be the mostest and the bestest
is it's really it's shallow it's very
shallow and I think education has as its
primary purpose the deepening of these
things you know the fundamental
questions about life and what we're what
we're about and what were why we're
doing things and to raise these not in
the sense of trying to depreciate all
the various activities of humankind but
rather to make sure that there's certain
focal points that that that's what I'm
concerned about and that's what I
continue to speak about and work for and
I'm proud of his role in that well thank
you and thanks for your legacy thanks
for the time this morning
well it's been a pleasure you tell I
enjoy it